[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Glad to have you here.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm dean at the
Radcliffe Institute.
And I'm so pleased
to welcome all of you
to Samantha Power's much
anticipated lecture, US Foreign
Policy From the Inside Out.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe embraces
a dual mission
to foster and to share
transformative ideas
across disciplines.
And we do this by
convening and supporting
scholars, scientists, artists,
and professionals working
at the forefront of their
fields and by organizing
a full calendar of
public programming,
including lectures, conferences,
performances, and exhibitions.
Now, today, we have
the opportunity
to hear from someone
who has grappled
with many of the
most daunting issues
facing the United
States and the world
and who has done so from a
number of different vantage
points.
As a journalist, a scholar, an
activist, and most recently,
as a senior executive
branch official,
Samantha Power has been on
the front lines, so to speak,
throughout her career
in foreign policy.
As a result of her
varied experiences,
Samantha is well-placed to
explore challenging questions
around how to balance means and
ends, pragmatism and idealism,
and competing priorities
in determining
the appropriate role
for the United States
on the world stage.
These questions
defy easy analysis,
and yet, they run through
much of Samantha's work.
In her first book, entitled
A Problem from Hell, America
and the Age of
Genocide, Samantha
indicts the US foreign
policy establishment
for falling short of
our nation's ideals
by failing to act against
genocide at critical moments
in embattled hotspots like
Cambodia, Iraq, Bosnia,
and Rwanda.
More than that, Samantha charges
that the US distanced itself
from these conflicts
which fell outside
of its narrow national interest
by deliberately sidestepping
moral responsibility.
A Problem from Hell won the 2002
National Book Critics Circle
Award for nonfiction
and the 2003 Pulitzer
Prize for nonfiction.
Samantha's second book,
Chasing the Flame,
Sergio Vieira de Mello and
the Fight to Save the World,
takes on difficult questions
about the proper role
of international diplomacy
and the proper conditions
for intervention in a
world where nations' moral
and strategic objectives
often compete.
Here, she explores the personal
and professional evolution
of Sergio Vieira de Mello,
a Brazilian-born diplomat
who served in the United Nations
for more than three decades
and who died tragically
in a 2003 suicide bombing
while acting as
Secretary-General Kofi Annan's
special representative in Iraq.
Chasing the Flame was also the
basis for an award-winning HBO
documentary entitled Sergio.
In Samantha's telling,
de Mello began his career
as someone who would freely
and forcefully denounce
evil and injustice
wherever he saw it,
but who then went
on to fully embrace
not only the necessity
of negotiation,
but also the United Nations'
powerful inclination towards
non-judgment.
He did this to such an extent
that some found him obsequious.
De Mello even
earned the nickname
Serbio for his
perceived closeness
to Slobodan Milosevic during the
Balkan War of the early 1990s.
Eventually, we learn, de
Mello struck a balance
between the poles of
denouncement and non-judgement
that Samantha holds up
as a model from which
our country can learn.
I quote her prescription.
"Be in the room, don't be afraid
of talking to your adversaries,
but don't bracket what happened
before you entered the room.
Don't black-box history.
Don't check your
principles at the door."
I suspect this kind of
principled pragmatism
combined with humility and what
Samantha has described as--
and I quote her-- "an emboldened
sense of responsibility"
has animated much of her
own efforts in recent years
at the senior-most levels
of US foreign policy making.
Her policy positions, as
many analysts have noted,
do not track with any
particular partisan agenda.
Moreover, Samantha is
well-known as someone
who presses her case with
both force and clarity.
And I might add here something
that her fellow fellows,
I think, will agree with, that
we in the Radcliffe community
have had the honor and
pleasure of observing Samantha
in action, as she has
interrogated her fellow fellows
on an impressively
broad range of topics
with the same
intensity and insight.
Whatever you may think of
the current administration
or the previous one, it
should be clear to all
that we face new and
often unprecedented
global challenges with
profound strategic and human
implications.
I am thrilled to have someone as
expert, as experienced, and as
wise as Samantha here today to
help us reflect on these issues
from the inside out,
to use her language,
and to suggest a way forward.
Samantha is the 2017-2018
Perrin Moorhead Grayson
and Bruns Grayson Fellow here
at the Radcliffe Institute.
And I'm happy to see Penny
Grayson here with us today.
I'm grateful to the Graysons
for their generous support
of the Institute and to Penny
for her advice as a member
of our Deans Advisory Council.
In addition to Samantha's
Radcliffe fellowship
this year, she is on the faculty
of both the Harvard Law School
and the Harvard Kennedy School.
Before returning to
Harvard last fall,
Samantha was a US permanent
representative to the United
Nations and a member of
President Barack Obama's
cabinet.
She also served as
special assistant
to the president and senior
director for Multinational--
Multilateral Affairs
and Human Rights
on the president's
National Security Council,
where she focused on UN
reform, LGBT and women's
rights, religious freedom,
human trafficking,
and democracy and human rights.
Samantha was the founding
executive director
of the Carr Center for Human
Rights at the Harvard Kennedy
School.
And in addition to her two
books that I mentioned earlier,
she is the co-editor of another
book entitled The Unquiet
American, Richard
Holbrooke in the World,
an examination of the career
and writings of another diplomat
Samantha admired greatly.
Samantha's other writings have
appeared in such publications
as The Atlantic, the New
Republic, The New York Review
of Books, and The New Yorker.
I will just add, before
making a final comment,
that I want to alert
you to the fact
that a film that
features Samantha
and her last year in
the Obama administration
is now out in the world,
available through YouTube
and I'm sure other--
how else?
Lots of different ways, and
the Kendall theater, too.
So you can see it at home
or you can see it in public.
But we highly recommend it.
Here's how the
afternoon will go.
After Samantha
delivers her lecture,
there'll be time
for a brief Q&A.
We will put a microphone
in the center aisle.
We invite you to line
up to ask your question.
Please introduce yourself
before you do so.
And after the final
question, I invite
you to join us for a reception
next door at Fay House.
Now, it gives me great
pleasure to welcome
Samantha Power to the podium.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
Great to be here.
And thank you so much,
Liz, for that introduction.
I'd like to start by offering a
fulsome thank you to Radcliffe,
the Radcliffe Institute, to the
Grayson family for having me
here as a fellow along with
such other amazing people
that I've had a chance to
listen to and learn from.
I was incredibly privileged
to get to serve in the Obama
administration for eight years.
But one of the
disadvantages of being
in national security
24/7 is it tends
to narrow your perspective.
And coming here
and learning about
facial-recognition technology
and pirates and cichlid fish
reminds me and
affirms for me why
it's so amazing to be on
a campus, and especially
this amazing campus.
So thank you.
It's wonderful to see so
many people here today who
could be doing a lot
of different things.
So thank you for coming out.
I have spent my time thus far--
I can't believe it's
slipping away, but trying
to understand the journey
that Liz described,
a journey that took me from
being, initially, a journalist
and activist and academic into
the messy world of politics,
and specifically into Barack
Obama's Senate office,
into his presidential campaign,
which I had to leave briefly,
and finally into the White
House, and most amazingly,
as his ambassador to the United
Nations in his second term.
In coming here today
and having the chance
to speak at Harvard for the
first time since I've returned
and to do my--
make my Radcliffe
presentation, I
considered a lot
of different topics
within the broad rubric
of foreign policy
from the inside out
because I'm exploring
a very broad range of topics.
The question I get asked
the most about, which
may come up in the
discussion period,
is the red line in Syria.
There's a lot to say about
the person currently occupying
the Oval Office and the future
of the liberal international
order.
I could have gone
in that direction.
But given the broader reckoning
going on in our country
and around the world, I
thought I would actually
use this occasion
here at Radcliffe,
of all places, to
reflect on a question
that I increasingly
get, which is, what
was it like, as a woman,
doing foreign policy in the US
government and at the UN?
And I stress, because
I am a professor here,
but this is not an
academic lecture.
It's not my normal
analytic fare.
It is one person's
personal experiences
from which I try to draw,
also, some lessons regarding
how we go forward in the face
of many of the challenges
that are being discussed
and aired, but many of which
are not yet being addressed.
So let me start a little
bit at the beginning.
Before I began working
in the US government,
I will admit that
I had never been
all that self-conscious about
being a woman in the workplace.
And this is partly
because I was raised
by a very single-minded Irish
mother, Vera Delaney, who
overcame such severe hurdles and
prejudices herself to do what
she loved, which was
to practice medicine,
that I compared my
lucky life, which
was very privileged, certainly,
in comparison to some
of the challenges she faced.
This is her.
This is me and my mother.
[INAUDIBLE] great.
She's really great.
But not long after she
married my father and had me,
my mother became a
doctor, at a time
when married women
made up less than 10%
of the Irish workforce.
I grew up on stories
of her experiences
in the medical
profession and in the--
in the world, which
often weren't pretty--
but they never deterred her,
she was full speed ahead--
like the one when she tried to
acquire custody of my younger
brother and me so she could
bring us to the United States
in order to be able to deepen
her training as a kidney
doctor.
And in the courtroom, the
justice mused out loud about
my mother-- who at that point,
had a PhD in biochemistry
and medical degree--
what right has this
woman to be so educated?
[LAUGHTER]
I know.
But these are the kinds
of stories I grew up on.
So I thought,
who's got problems?
My first real job was as a
23-year-old war correspondent
in the Balkans.
Now, of course, it
was men, mainly,
who orchestrated and fought
the wars that I was covering.
Interestingly, though, among
the posse of freelancers
and full-time correspondents
who gravitated to the Balkans,
it was women war correspondents
who really, at that time,
I think, stood out, everyone
from Christiane Amanpour
of CNN, of course, to Maggie
O'Kane of the Guardian, who
uncovered concentration
camps in northern Bosnia,
Kate Adie of the BBC, Carol
Williams of the LA Times.
These were amazing
role models for me
and my girlfriends, who
are still my closest
friends, to have at that stage.
And although the culture that
we encountered in the Balkans
was patriarchal in the
extreme, although not compared
to what some of our
people here I know
have gone through-- but with
very deep-rooted sexism,
writing for the Western
media in Bosnia in the 1990s
was a far cry for women from
what Martha Gellhorn had
gone through to try to cover the
D-Day invasion of World War II.
Some of you know
the story where she
had to hide in the
toilet of a hospital ship
and to sneak ashore
with an ambulance crew
in order to cover the landing.
I can't be scientific
about the difference
that gender made in Bosnia.
And it is even
conceivable that we
women correspondents,
of whom there were many,
actually enjoyed better access
to the people and events we
wished to cover because the
local gunmen so underestimated
us.
But that said, I also don't know
a single woman colleague who
wasn't, at one point,
caught off guard
by a romantic
come-on from a source
or left stammering her way
out of an unexpected advance.
I must admit, again, that
I had not reflected much
on the role that gender
played in my career at all,
really, until
recently, when hundreds
of brave women, and a few
men, began coming forward
to share their personal
experiences of harassment,
predation, assault,
exposing decades
of toxic and illegal behavior
by people in positions of power.
Like everything in this stage--
in this age, I should say,
it has a hashtag, #MeToo.
But unlike so many other issues
that have burst into the news
and then just as
quickly disappeared,
#MeToo has become more
impactful on the national
and the global conversation
than I think any of us
could have imagined
when we first
read about Harvey Weinstein,
for example, last fall.
These silence breakers,
as Time magazine
called its 2017
person of the year,
have jumpstarted a
long-overdue reckoning.
It is reaching across
professions and party lines,
shining a light on the invisible
daily struggles endured
for too long by our mentors, our
teachers, friends, colleagues,
neighbors, grandmothers,
mothers, and even
our own daughters.
It is no wonder, then, that
this reckoning has also
reached the field of national
security and foreign policy.
Two months ago, in
November, 223 women
who work in or on US
national security,
including many close colleagues
of mine from the Obama
administration,
signed an open letter
that they titled #MeTooNatSec.
You don't have to
read the letter.
I do recommend
looking for it online.
But that's just to give
you a hint of the letter.
The letter is addressed to
the entire national security
community.
And it was quite
measured in tone.
It made no sensational claims
about specific abusers,
nor did it call out any
particular government agency,
declaring, quote, "We,
too, are survivors
of sexual harassment,
assault, and abuse
or know others who
are," end quote.
Ambassadors,
professors, diplomats,
intelligence analysts, military
officers, think-tankers,
and leading experts from every
part of the foreign policy
community delivered a
stinging assessment.
And I'll just read you
part of the letter.
"Many women are
held back or driven
from the national
security field by men
who use their power to assault
at one end of the spectrum
and perpetuate, sometimes
unconsciously, environments
that silence, demean, belittle,
or neglect women at the other.
Assault is the progression
of the same behaviors
that permit us to be denigrated,
interrupted, shut out--
[COUGH]
--excuse me, shut
out, and shut up.
These behaviors incubate
a permissive environment
where sexual harassment
and assault take hold."
So that's just a
part of the letter.
So this letter only received
fleeting media coverage,
but it did generate significant
attention in the foreign policy
world.
And among those reacting were
the 10 Democrats on the Senate
Foreign Relations
Committee who forwarded
this letter to
Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson with a warning that a
failure to remedy the problems
it described would have
what the senators called
a deep and negative affect
on US national security.
Well beyond the letter,
in recent months--
again, a little
beneath the radar
compared to some of what's
in the press each day--
women in national
security have come forward
to share their experiences
of indignities and abuses,
large and small, themselves
overcoming or combating,
overriding the longstanding
concern that speaking out
would torpedo their careers.
I'll offer just
two stark examples.
One widely-shared frustration
is the demeaning, often flippant
attitude men in the
national security realm
have expressed toward the
professional advancement
or achievement of their
female colleagues.
Heather Hurlburt, who
is a former speechwriter
in the White House and
the State Department,
recalled being hired
for her dream job,
only to be told by
her boss, quote,
"We held this job open for
a woman, so I hired you
and dated the other
finalist," end quote.
Not ideal.
Others have spoken to
the dangerous culture
of entitlement and
impunity that prevails
in a profession that entails,
often, long foreign trips
and long hours.
Rosa Brooks-- some of you may
have seen this-- a defense
official in the
Obama administration,
described a harrowing experience
from earlier in her career
with a senior foreign service
Officer who, as she put it,
quote, "grabbed me and
shoved his tongue forcibly
down my throat as we walked
along a deserted canal
in Venice, returning from an
international law conference.
It took several minutes of
skirmishing and several firm
threats to shove
him into the canal
before he stopped pawing
at me," end quote.
Now, this problem is
obviously widespread well
beyond the national security
community, as we all know,
and certainly well
beyond the United States.
Just last week, in
fact, the Guardian
published a devastating
expose describing
pervasive sexual harassment,
assault, and retaliation
across the UN, often
perpetrated by senior officials.
A former investigator for the
UN's internal affairs division
told the paper that he
routinely witnessed cover-ups
and that impunity for
offenders was the norm.
As he put it, "the
only rule is not
to publicly embarrass
the Organization,"
capital "O," Organization.
Taking stock of the
many experiences shared
by female national
security professionals,
the political
scientist, Dan Drezner,
described women in
this field as facing
what he called a
gender tax, something
that our male counterparts
don't shoulder.
Speaking more
personally, I think
it is fair to say that the first
time I began to focus on what
it meant to be a
woman in the workplace
was when I started to
work in Washington.
And let me be clear.
On that score and
on many others,
I feel extremely
fortunate to have worked
for President Obama, the son
of a trailblazing mother,
the husband of a woman
who was once his boss,
and the dedicated father of two
daughters who has said proudly,
"It's important that
their dad is a feminist,
because now that's what
they expect of men."
In his eight years as
president-- you miss him,
don't you?
I know, sorry--
Obama appointed the
highest number of women
to cabinet-level
positions in US history.
And I must say-- and
this mattered to me
a lot-- he always
gave the impression
that he wasn't scurrying
around with women in binders
or whatever it was
that we heard about,
that someone had to make
this huge effort in order
to find talented women.
He projected the
sense that he was
hiring the people who were
the best for the job, who
happened to be women.
Nonetheless, in 2009, while
women ran key government
agencies, at the
White House itself,
where I would work
for four years,
men held 2/3 of the top jobs.
And this wasn't
a new phenomenon.
It was not until the Eisenhower
administration in 1953
that women began to
work in the West Wing
as more than secretaries.
The culture at the White
House bore similarities
to office dynamics across
this great country,
lots of sports metaphors
and sports outings
to play basketball or golf,
ample "dude" references,
and lots and lots of swearing.
I was fortunate to
play basketball.
So I had opportunities
to do business
with senior officials outside
of our long hours in the office.
I won't speak to
the swearing part.
The most vivid occasion
on which gender
dynamics at the White
House surfaced publicly
came in December 2012
during negotiations
over the so-called fiscal cliff
when the White House released
a photo of President Obama
seated in the Oval Office
with his back to the
camera, giving direction
to his political, economics, and
communications teams, as such.
When critics pounced
on this photo-- someone
released this photo.
Someone very senior would
have released this photo,
not thinking that
there was anything
weird about this photo.
So we start with that.
So when critics saw the
photo, the White House
pointed out something
even worse than releasing
the photo itself.
Some of you may remember.
Does anybody remember that,
in fact, if you look closely,
you will see, behind Dan
Pfeiffer in his brown corduroys
and blue shirt,
Valerie Jarrett's leg.
[LAUGHTER]
She was there all along.
And literally, you
had statements,
people on and off the record,
coming out saying, oh, no, it's
fine.
Look, there's her knee.
You could just see in the--
Anyway, so you can imagine
the reaction to this.
Jodi Kantor of the New York
Times tweeted "Jarrett's leg
as metaphor."
Now, President Obama,
the enlightened guy
that he is, of course, invited
senior women on the White House
staff to his office or
he had dinners with them
so that they could vent,
share frustrations,
get a sense of what could
be done differently.
And I think that
more self-awareness
and deliberateness meant that
women were called on more
often-- and sometimes even
when they weren't raising
their hands, which happens
not only at Harvard campus,
but within the White
House as well--
and also affirming the
work of his women advisors.
But I think, as we all
know, numbers matter.
And it was significant
that in the second term,
President Obama and his very
activist chief of staff, Denis
McDonough, went out
of their way to try
to ensure that women occupied
an equal share of the top White
House staff jobs.
And in fact, in
2015, the White House
released a not-so-subtle photo
of the president conferring
with his advisors.
[INAUDIBLE], yes.
And Obama's
photographer, Pete Souza,
later commented, "This
is a full-frame picture.
I guess you'd say I was
trying to make a point."
So at the National
Security Council,
which is where I worked-- it
was part of the White House,
but its own world--
in the early years of
the Obama administration,
men held all the top jobs,
national security advisor,
deputy national security
advisor, homeland security
advisor, chief of staff,
strategic communications
advisor, and speechwriter.
The senior staff were known
as-- are known, I think,
maybe that's one thing
that's still intact--
are still known, perhaps,
as senior directors,
NSC senior directors.
And my first year, I was
one of six women who were
senior directors out of 26.
That gives you some
sense of the ratio.
One Wednesday toward the
end of our first year, one
of my senior women
colleagues-- it
was a fellow senior
director-- invited
me and a few other women
to come to her office
for a glass of wine.
This quick break turned
into a 90-minute release.
And after a half an hour
together, each of us
called back to our assistance
to ask apologetically
if they could move our
next appointments owing
to urgent national
security business.
We discussed not only our
experience of work at the NSC
and some of our
frustrations, but also
what we were working on,
what we were proud of,
what we hoped to achieve.
This first pretty
spontaneous invitation
turned into a sacred
weekly Wednesday group.
Those of us with kids
talked about the chaos
of our juggling.
The single women among us talked
about their latest crushes.
Each of us gave each other
a quality of attention
that was too often lacking
in the transactional world
of Washington.
And outside of
these gatherings, I
think a change
crept into the way
that we acted in our
larger policy discussions.
Without ever discussing it or
making any conscious shift--
at least that I'm aware of--
we reflexively supported
one another in meetings.
Now, this didn't mean we
agreed with one another.
Some of my most spirited
arguments at the NSC
were with my fellow
women senior directors.
We were not always on the
same page, by any means.
But we engaged one another's
arguments, not simply leaving
them hanging in the air, which
happened too often in larger
group discussions.
As we compared notes
during what became known,
again, as this--
the Wednesday group,
I was struck both by how
self-conscious my colleagues
were as women role
models to younger women
and by the lengths
to which these women,
the senior directors,
went to seek out and hire
young women to work directly
under them as directors.
And I just have to stress
how challenging this
is to do in the world of foreign
policy and national security.
You really have to
fight gravity in order
to have the kind of equality
of representation that we seek.
And why is that?
The pipeline, the
so-called pipeline
of women eligible to go into
senior foreign policy positions
in government is very skewed.
In academia, a key feeder to
these top national security
jobs, the ratio of men
to women professors
who focus on US foreign policy
back when I was in the Obama--
starting in the Obama
administration was 3 to 1.
Of the top 10
American think tanks
concentrating on
international affairs,
just one was then
run by a woman.
When CNN, Fox, and MSNBC--
so the range-- had
foreign policy segments,
they chose male commentators
a remarkable 80% of the time.
And so even though in recent
memory Madeleine Albright,
Condoleezza Rice,
Hillary Clinton
have run the State
Department, we
can't forget that
until 1971, women
Foreign Service
Officers at State
had to retire if
they got married.
And only 9% of US ambassadors
have been women since
the country's-- since
our country's founding.
More often than not-- and
this remains true today--
the women ambassadors
are posted to countries
considered less central
to US national security.
No woman has yet
served as ambassador--
US ambassador to China,
to Russia, Israel, Turkey,
or Afghanistan.
And I think it's fair to say
the same basic story applies
across government agencies, like
CIA and the Defense Department.
I came to understand that
hiring men and women in roughly
equal numbers at the
NSC really required
pushing water uphill, slowing
down the hiring process at just
the time that,
given the workload,
you were inclined
to speed it up,
and proactively
reaching out to women
to urge them to throw
their hats in the ring,
or trying to appeal to
them and to overcome
the doubts that they have about
even taking jobs of this nature
given some of the reputational
issues that also existed.
Jim Clapper, President
Obama's Director
of National Intelligence,
made the case
for more proactive
hiring this way.
He said, "Over my 53-plus years
in the intelligence business--"
that's a lot of years--
"I've watched women rise
to leadership positions
all around me.
And having women
in leadership roles
is more critical than people
on the outside would think.
We have found that with almost
all the major intelligence
failures we've had, diversity
of thought might have saved us,"
end quote.
And speaking about the equally
troubling absence of people
of color in the field
of national security
or foreign policy, President
Obama's National Security
Advisor, Susan Rice,
put it perfectly.
"Our national security
agencies have not yet
drawn fully on the strengths
of our great nation.
In the halls of power, in the
faces of our national security
leaders, America is still
not fully reflected."
And that was before
the cabinet came
to look like founding fathers.
So fortunately for me, even
though there were far more men
than women at the NSC,
as I've indicated,
I rarely found myself the
only woman in the room.
And there were all--
again, all these ways
in which I think we found a
way to reinforce one another.
And the culture did evolve,
importantly, over time.
Things were very different when
I got to the United Nations,
when I became President Obama's
second ambassador to the United
Nations, where you
really often were
the only woman in the room.
So since World War II
when the UN was created,
enshrining within
its founding charter
the critical importance
of human rights
and fundamental
freedoms, there has never
been a woman Secretary-General.
And the percentage of women
ambassadors representing
the various member
states, which--
and this would just reflect the
dynamics within the countries
that comprise the UN--
has never exceeded 25%.
Now, I was really lucky,
because I didn't represent
any old country at the UN.
I represented the United
States, the country
that hosts the UN on its soil.
We are the largest
financial donor to the UN
by leaps and bounds.
We have the veto.
One of five countries
at the UN have the veto.
We bring our policy
initiatives there.
As a result, I think
it's fair to say
that over my time at the UN,
the salience of my Americanness
was more relevant or
evident to other countries
than me being a woman was.
And so I think I suffered very
few of the kinds of slights
that I know from my
colleagues, women colleagues,
that they suffered.
Madeleine Albright
liked to joke, quote,
"It used to be that the
only way a woman could truly
make her foreign policy views
felt was by marrying a diplomat
and then pouring tea on an
offending ambassador's lap."
By the time I assumed
my position in 2013,
a trio of amazingly strong
women had served at the UN,
representing the United States
before me, Jeane Kirkpatrick,
1981 to 1985, Albright herself,
'93 to '97 before she became
our first woman
secretary of state,
and Ambassador
Rice, 2009 to 2013.
So when I got to New York,
I read the biographies
by Jeane Kirkpatrick and
about Jeane Kirkpatrick
and by Secretary
Albright herself.
And I think when you read
biographies of women who've
served in prior
generations, you really
see how much has
changed for the better.
And I'm just going to give you
a flavor of that here today.
Jeane Kirkpatrick, raised
in a small town in Oklahoma,
ducked out of an early
stint in government
to raise her three sons
while she was competing
her doctorate at Columbia.
She was discovered in 1979--
that's the year I came to this
country from Ireland--
after Dick Allen, Ronald
Reagan's foreign policy advisor
in the presidential campaign,
gave Reagan an essay
that she had written
in commentary, which
you all probably
are familiar with,
called "Dictatorships
and Double Standards."
Reagan, who had just
announced that he was running
for president, read the essay
on a flight from Washington
to Los Angeles and called
Allen very excitedly
when he got home.
"What you gave me to read was
extraordinary," Reagan said.
"Who is this guy,
Jeane Kirkpatrick?"
Kirkpatrick was almost
always the only woman
in the room at the
UN and in Washington.
During her four years
in New York at the UN,
she was one of just three
women ambassadors out
of the then 157 UN member
states, three out of 157.
She served with also a woman
ambassador from Liberia
and from the Seychelles.
The Soviet Union, just to give
you an indicator, has had,
actually, 11 ambassadors
in their mission.
The United States has five.
Soviet Union had
11, none a woman.
She later recalled how
people interacted with her
or treated her.
She said, quote,
"it rocked them.
I think they just regarded
me as a very odd creature,"
end quote.
Now, the Washington glass
ceiling she shattered
is, in many ways, just
as important, if not more
important.
She was the first
woman in history
to have a seat at the table
in the high-level debates.
Now we'd call it the
Principals Committee.
Then they had
another name for it.
But basically, your
national security
cabinet, first woman ever.
Again, I was new to the
United States, an immigrant
with my mother and
my younger brother.
But a photo that really stuck in
my mind from when I was a kid--
I know, it's amazing--
was this one, and
seeing Kirkpatrick there
among the suits at the
center of the shot.
Now, soon after-- soon after
she was chosen UN ambassador,
a friend of hers reported that
Secretary of State Alexander
Haig had reacted to the news of
her appointment by exclaiming,
"I don't know how
anybody expects that I
will work with that bitch."
Secretary Haig, who famously
craved the diplomatic limelight
himself, accused Kirkpatrick
of being temperamental--
sound familiar?--
mentally and emotionally
incapable of thinking clearly,
especially during the Falklands
Crisis, when their
relationship came to a head.
Even those who
respected Kirkpatrick--
of whom there were many at the
time-- treated her differently,
I think, it's fair to say.
In the spring of 1983, Chief
of Staff Mike Deaver told her,
"Everyone notices
you have influence
with President Reagan."
When Kirkpatrick shrugged,
Deaver went on, "No, no, no.
Everyone notices.
He always listens
when you speak.
He looks at you and
his eyes light up.
Maybe it's because
you're a woman."
Kirkpatrick shot
back, "Maybe it's
because he's interested
in foreign policy."
President Clinton appointed
Madeleine Albright
to the UN ambassadorship
less than a decade later.
By this time, she was
not the sole woman
in the traditional
cabinet photo.
For Albright, also,
sitting behind the placard
in New York that said
United States of America
had special resonance.
She was a Czech
immigrant, but a refugee.
Her refugee family had
come to this country.
And she remains, to
this day, incredibly
grateful to this country
for welcoming her
in and very
outspoken about, now,
the curbs on incoming
refugee flow.
Albright married young,
three days after her college
graduation, and took
the long road, 13 years,
to completing her
doctorate at Georgetown
while she raised
her three daughters.
She was frustrated
that the skills
she was honing as a
multi-tasking mother
carried little weight in
the professional world.
As she would later put
it, "Senior vice president
for communications sounds
so much more important than
'put out school newsletter.'"
Albright did not hold
a full-time job until
she was 39 years old.
When I was nominated
to become UN ambassador
and I went to see
Secretary Albright,
she told me that when
she had been at the UN,
she had convened a group
for women ambassadors.
And then, when she was there--
again, there were more
countries in the world
as well than when
Kirkpatrick had been there--
there were 183 countries.
And only seven of
those countries
were represented by women.
So Albright branded
her group the G7.
Not the group of seven,
the girls' seven.
And they traded gossip.
They shared family experiences.
And they really, I
think importantly,
became a cross-regional lobby
on behalf of women's issues,
even managing to
get two women judges
onto the bench of the new UN war
crimes tribunal, which was just
being set up.
Now, I had way more female
company when I got to New York
in 2013.
I was the one of 37 women
permanent representatives out
of 193 countries, again,
more countries than in '93.
But that's still
just 20% overall,
which is quite
similar, actually,
to our own Congress, the ratio.
And again, the UN tends to
be reflective of how things
are within national systems.
Now, on the most
powerful UN body,
which is the 15-member
UN Security Council,
I had the chance in 2014 to
serve with four other women.
There were five of us--
the United States, Nigeria,
Luxembourg, Jordan,
and Lithuania.
We were the largest
female contingent
on the council in the
seven-decade history of the UN.
And though we only
accounted-- we didn't all
sit together, actually.
This was a panel.
But maybe we should have.
Though we only accounted for
a third of the membership
on the premiere UN body
responsible for making
international law, deciding
on the use of force,
sanctions, et cetera, the
excitement around the UN
was palpable in this period
where we had the chance
to serve together.
Young women would pull
me aside in the restroom,
in the ladies restroom,
to say how proud they
were to see five women
duking it out in the usually
male Security Council chamber.
And the longer I served, though,
also apart from how it looked
and the signal that that sent,
which I'll come back to--
the longer I served,
the more evidence I
saw of the functional value,
as well, of this gender parity.
Having more women
on the council,
just simply put, changed the
nature of our deliberations.
We weren't perfect at
listening to one another,
but I think it's fair to say we
listened to one another more.
With more women
colleagues on the council,
we also talked more, as it
happened, about sexual violence
and about the importance
of including women
in peace processes, from which
they are so often shut out.
Nonetheless, even
with us there--
and we were a formidable group.
I mean, the character of
the individuals involved
were very, very
strong in each case.
Just even having that
presence didn't, of course,
stop our some of
our male colleagues
from saying completely crazy
things behind closed doors.
On several occasions,
male ambassadors
questioned whether
well-documented cases
of rape as an atrocity
in war had occurred.
And I'll just quote
you from one of them.
"Why would the
soldiers have done
this when they have their
wives to come home to?"
one of my African
colleagues asked.
"Where's the proof?
If these rapes really
happened, any woman victim
would want to talk about it.
They wouldn't care if
security forces were present."
So I asked-- this is
the advantage, again,
of at least being in the
room where it happens.
I asked, oh, are
you speaking from
your vast personal experience
of having been raped
and then being
asked what happened
while security forces affiliated
with your rapist leered
over you?
Is that how you are an
authority on this matter?
The Russian
ambassador, memorably--
it's become the stuff of
legend in the small circle that
is New York, but criticized the
UN's Yemen envoy for spending
too much of his precious time
on the ground talking to women.
"Your job is to make peace and
that is a hard enough job,"
the Russian ambassador said.
"Why are you wasting
your time having meetings
with women who aren't even
involved in the conflict?"
That's an important point.
So let's spend all our time
with the men who are fueling
the conflict and won't stop.
In each of these
instances and many others,
the heads of the women
ambassadors present and some
of the male
ambassadors, of course,
as well would snap to attention.
And each of us would
fling our hand up
in the air to seek the floor to
challenge what had been said.
Unfortunately, in 2016, the
number of women ambassadors
dwindled back down
to 1 out of 15.
There she is.
That's me.
And it remained that way
until just a few weeks ago
when Karen Pierce became
the first woman in history
to represent the United
Kingdom at the United Nations,
joining now Ambassador
Nikki Haley.
In my years in government,
as I alluded to earlier,
I developed a heightened
appreciation for symbols.
And one of the most moving
photographs taken during
the Obama presidency was this
one of Jacob Philadelphia--
this was 2009--
just tentatively reaching up
to just-- to feel, to see,
to be sure, could it
really be the case
that this African-American
man with hair just
like this little
boy's was, in fact,
President of the United States?
So what we see matters
hugely, changes
our sense of what's possible.
And when I would sit in the open
chamber of the Security Council
as the only woman
permanent representative,
I would often see
the school tour
groups that would come
into the UN in New York.
And they're escorted
into the viewing gallery.
They sit there.
They watch 10, 15
minutes of the debate.
And I just found
myself wondering,
what must these children think?
They look down at this famous
horseshoe where world history
has sometimes been made.
And is the ambition of these
girls altered by the sense
that there's one
out of 15 people
as a woman at this table,
and the boys' sense--
for both-- of what is normal
shaped again by that picture?
So needless to say,
in the 21st century,
it should not and
should never have
been seen as normal for
women to have only one seat
at that table or any table.
So I am working on a
book about my experiences
in government
provisionally titled
The Education of an Idealist, a
title that will likely change,
because why is it only idealists
who get educated, I ask you,
but nonetheless, gives
you a sense of what
I'm trying to track.
But in part, because of all
that is going on around us now
and the bravery of women
across so many domains,
I am asking myself questions
that I haven't really
asked before.
Has my professional life been
impacted more by these issues
than I recognized?
Was I, at times, dismissed
or underestimated
because of my gender?
Have I myself blocked
out various dimensions
of the problem, and
in so doing, failed
to do as much as I should
have myself in the positions
that I've had to
combat this phenomenon?
And how can I equip
my young daughter
to handle what
lies ahead for her?
So I'm still wrestling with
these personal questions.
And I don't have
great answers yet.
But I have, for the
purposes of today, at least,
tried to distill what
are the lessons for now,
at least as I can offer them up.
So here are a few ideas,
at least, humbly put,
tentatively put.
But first, I think women
have a wonderful opportunity
and responsibility to have
the backs of other women.
I tried to use my
perch at the UN
to push for women's voices
to be heard around the world.
Often, I was unsuccessful.
But at times, we were able
to line the moons up in a way
that I think mattered.
One example is that I launched
a campaign called #FreeThe20,
which was aimed at securing the
release of 20 women political
prisoners around the world.
These are voices of women
that were being silenced
in Egypt, Ethiopia,
Venezuela, China,
a whole bunch of countries.
And here were the 20 women.
I would hang-- each
day for 20 days,
we hung a portrait of one of
the women and profiled them.
And social media and the State
Department and the White House
got behind it, as did
members of Congress.
And I think, thanks to a lot of
advocacy, and particularly that
by outside groups
who have nothing
to do with the US
government-- but in the end,
together, 16 of the 20
prisoners we profiled
gained their freedom.
The other thing I did was--
and, again, much of what
I did was ineffective.
What I'm about to describe felt
like there was a power to it,
but very, very hard
to know, certainly
in the short term, but just
a simple thing that all of us
have in our power
to do today, which
is just while traveling
abroad as UN ambassador,
just insisting on
every one of my trips
that I would just
meet with young girls
in difficult situations
and just talk to them
about their aspirations.
And most of these
girls, you can imagine,
had never met a high-ranking
female official.
In Mexico, I met with a group
of underprivileged girls
in a soccer league,
played soccer with them.
In Nigeria, I met with
a group of schoolgirls
from Chibok, which many of you
know from the news who-- these
were girls who had been
captured by Boko Haram,
but then mercifully had
escaped in the early part
of their captivity.
In the war-ravaged north of Sri
Lanka, meeting with Buddhist
and Muslim girls who
were learning how to
live together again.
And in Israel and the
Palestinian territories,
sitting down with
honor students who
dreamed of becoming
engineers, architects,
and even a few politicians.
So, I mean, the hurdles
that these girls faced
were unimaginable.
But again, the ferocity of their
determination and discipline
left me and the
members of my team
completely blown
away and inspired.
We still have a
huge amount of work
to do in ensuring
women and girls abroad
and at home have the
confidence to pursue
the ambitions that they
think up for themselves.
I'll give you an American
statistic that's quite jarring.
American men are
both more likely
to see themselves as qualified
to run for political office
and much more likely to receive
encouragement from family
and friends to do so.
A pair of studies--
one from 2001, one 2011--
found that men were almost 60%
more likely than women
to describe themselves
as very qualified to be a
candidate, even though the men
and women surveyed were both
equally experienced in terms
of fundraising, policy
knowledge, et cetera.
A follow-on report that
focused on young people
similarly found that
female college students
are less likely than their male
peers to feel that they have
what it takes to run for office.
And that's, again, more recent.
This self-doubt manifests
itself in a whole bunch
of very subtle ways.
A fascinating survey-- oh,
you can't actually see it--
of Americans age 15 to 24 was
released just two weeks ago.
And it confirmed what
we have all been seeing.
Young women
distinguished themselves
as much more politically engaged
than their male counterparts
in 2017.
And that was on everything from
volunteering to donating money
to attending demonstrations.
At the same time, a much
higher percentage of women
cited a lack of knowledge
about the issues
or a fear of undue
criticism as explanations
for why they decided not
to be politically active.
As teachers,
parents, and mentors,
we've got to somehow
find a way to continue
to narrow and close, in the
end, this confidence gap.
Second, if we want
to make change,
we who share a
desire to see change
must embrace politics
in all of its messiness.
I don't know.
That's sort of the
biggest realization
I have on all national
security issues,
and certainly on this issue,
anything related to gender.
There's really no
obvious door number two.
Politics, politics, politics.
And here, again, some
good news, EMILY's List,
which for more
than three decades
has been tracking the
number of women who have
come forward to run for office--
EMILY's List, as you know,
has existed for 32 years
and it helps recruit and
elect pro-choice women.
But it reported that in
2016, the 32-year-old record
was shattered, that 920
women had come forward
seeking information about
how to run for office.
Now, in 2017, the year that
just closed out, the 920 was--
looks like the 19th century,
22,000 women reached out.
So that just gives you a sense,
like that was the prior record.
And that's captured in a lot of
what we read about, of course,
in terms of women's engagement.
Between 2016 and now,
the number of women
running for congressional or
statewide offices has doubled.
And in those crucial races
for control of the House,
so far there are
389 women running,
the most female
candidates ever seeking
to become a US representative.
And women are not only running.
They are winning.
In Virginia, 11 of the
14 women candidates
for the House of Delegates
backed by EMILY's List
won their races, 11 out of 14.
Many of these women were
firsts for the Virginia House,
the first Latina, the
first Asian-American,
the first lesbian, and the
first transgender woman.
Signing ceremony looks a
little different than often.
But we must acknowledge, of
course, that change is slow.
And incremental gains
never seem to be enough.
At the current rate of
progress, without knowing,
now, the outcome of 2018, where
so many more women are getting
involved, but--
so putting that to one side.
But it would, unless that
makes a major difference,
take another 75 years to achieve
gender parity in Congress
and 152 years for
state governors.
Now, that's not what
it's going to take.
It's going to take a
lot less than that.
But that's if we
were to extrapolate
on the basis of
where we are now.
Shelly Simmons, a name
you might remember
from the news of the
last couple months,
tied for her Virginia seat.
And she lost, then, if
you can call it that,
because of the random
drawing to break the tie that
went in her opponent's favor.
And afterward, she said, "I'm
my usual, angry, pissed-off self
about the situation.
Next time, I'm not
going to lose."
And it seems like it will
take that kind of resilience
and determination to accelerate
those numbers and the pace
of change.
Third-- and I only have four--
I think those of us who have
been fortunate enough to obtain
high-profile roles
as women leaders--
my own view is that
we could afford
to be more open about the
doubts and the challenges
that we face.
Madeleine Albright I've always
really admired for doing this.
She has often talked about being
the only woman at the table
in policy debates and thinking--
and these are her words--
"OK, well, I don't
think I'll say that.
It might sound stupid.
And then some man says
it and everybody thinks
it's completely brilliant.
And you were so mad at yourself
for not saying something."
And that's Madeleine.
Across male-dominated
fields, women
experience many of
the same dynamics.
But we don't always
seek each other out
to learn from one another.
And I know that, while I
never would have been the one
to create this Wednesday group
I told you about at the NSC,
I'm so glad that
one of my colleagues
had the insight to do so.
The busier one is, the
less time one feels
one has for such initiatives.
But I think they offer
consolation and inspiration
at once.
We women are often the jugglers
if we happen to have kids.
No amount of leaning in appears
to have changed the fact
that we are the ones likely to
be orchestrating the carpool
and making sure our kids
brush their teeth properly.
Sorry, I'm sure there are
amazing male parents here.
In my household, the
modernity has not yet
struck on these matters.
He's out of town, so I can--
I get away with this.
But feel free to bring it
up the next time you see him
at Harvard Law School.
Some women perform
the miracle juggle.
I mean, most women
perform the miracle
juggle without
advertising it, somehow
managing their jobs
or their home lives
as if with their
left hands, making
it look easy from the outside.
I have been incredibly lucky
to have a lot of support
for my juggle, including
my mother and my parents.
But I've never found it
easy and have always--
or at least, since I've
been in public life,
advertised those challenges
for what they're worth.
The time I really
started doing that was
when I had a grueling
confirmation hearing because
of what I had written as an
activist and an academic.
It was very difficult to
go before the US Senate
and then have to
answer for everything
I'd said and written
my entire life.
So it was difficult.
And the gavel sounded.
Finally, it was over.
And I prepared for it for weeks.
And my four-year-old
son jumped into my arms.
I know.
And he's such a ham.
He was like, yay, I've been
waiting for this my whole life.
And a good few--
you can't see it,
but basically, a scrum
of reporters came
and they start
snapping this photo.
And it was published in
a good few newspapers.
It's a lovely photo of my son.
And it just captures
my relief, I think,
at surviving my
confirmation hearing.
But what amazed
me about this was
I started getting notes from all
over the country, and even some
from around the world, just
saying how heartened they
were to see somebody attempting
a national security cabinet
role with small children in tow.
And again, I just didn't--
that wasn't my orientation.
I didn't think in those
terms, and then began
to be much more public
about some of the dimensions
to my juggling.
So this meant speaking about
the inelegance of my efforts
to work and mother
at the same time.
This was my approach, not the
one I recommend for everybody.
So I might have mentioned
publicly several times
how I breastfed my
daughter while on the phone
with the UN
Secretary-General talking
about a chemical
weapons attack in Syria.
Or the way in which--
in order to explain my
absences to my boy, Declan,
I taught him more about
Vladimir Putin and Crimea
than is probably healthy
for a seven-year-old.
But the point is,
every woman has
her own way of managing
their very particular juggle
and so too makes up her
own mind-- the same true
with working dads, of course,
as well-- about how transparent
to be about that challenge.
My conscious
decision, particularly
in the wake of the reaction
I had to this photo,
was to overshare, which
may be a weakness of mine.
Fourth and finally,
even amid the cruelty
being perpetrated by our
current president and the desire
many of us have to change
the whole world at once,
I think figuring out how
to be good with bite-sized
contributions and doing
what each of us can do,
what is-- identifying
and pursuing what
is in each of our power to do.
It's about what is one's
specific difference.
What is the specific
difference each of us can make?
And it is going to be millions
of small contributions
that ultimately produce the
kind of equality that we seek.
And here, it was a
Martin Luther King--
I love Martin Luther King
quotes, constantly been
quoting them my whole life.
But I had never seen this quote,
but is now my favorite Martin
Luther King quote, "Be a
bush if you can't be a tree.
If you can't be a
highway, just be a trail.
If you can't be
a sun, be a star,
for it isn't by size
that you win or fail.
Be the best at
whatever you are."
And here, inspired a
little bit by a talk
that Kathryn Sikkink
gave on Tuesday,
I would point to the
simple act even of voting,
which all citizens have it
within their power to do.
And focusing
specifically on women,
it is devastating to note that,
while women still generally
vote more than men in the United
States, female turnout in 2016
was down when compared
to 2004, 2008, and 2012.
Given the stakes
and the consequences
that we're living
every day, that's
something we have got to remedy.
And that's with the chance
to elect even the first woman
president in American history.
We have to find a way to
rally our family and friends,
having worked so hard
to secure for women
a voice in American
political life,
encouraging women
to raise that voice
and insist that they be heard.
In addition-- and
this is just because I
feel like every talk that's
in any way about politics
or public policy needs to
address this in some fashion.
But I think part, again,
of our small contributions
before we are able to
make the big ones relates
to political polarization.
Speaking here directly to
women, if we are mothers,
we are talking
incessantly about our kids
to other mothers and fathers.
Now, in the Republic
of Cambridge,
it may be that we don't--
there isn't a huge amount
of diversity there.
But in most communities,
it is still--
there is more plurality
in those communities
than is reflected by
our electoral maps.
And I think, again,
all of us, as people
who are parts of
families, want our leaders
to solve practical
problems for our families.
So here, again, just
we can all do better
at trying to listen
to one another
and be prepared to change
our minds, something that
gets harder and harder
given what is coming at us,
trying to reclaim this
world of facts and truth
and putting our minds to
the larger epistemological
challenge of how
we go about that
and focusing on what unites
us, which notwithstanding,
again, the group of
people that appear
to want to go in a
different direction,
wanting security and
dignity for our families
and our communities
really does--
it can unite the vast majority
of people in this country.
And in the spirit of talking
about aspiring to breaking down
some of the echo chambers in
our country and our culture,
I would note that this national
reckoning that I've referred to
and that is so much with
us in so many spheres
right now was kicked
off by none other
than Gretchen Carlson, a
longtime Fox News anchor who,
for many years, hosted Fox
& Friends, Donald Trump's
favorite TV show.
And as a direct result
of Carlson's bravery
in coming forward with her
stories of sexual harassment,
Roger Ailes resigned
as president of Fox.
This started a
domino effect that
led to the dismissal of Bill
O'Reilly and top network
executives.
And today, Gretchen
Carlson is a major force
behind pursuing bipartisan
legislation that is now
pending before Congress,
which would invalidate
unfair mandatory arbitration
clauses that allow employers
to cover up patterns of
abuse by preventing employees
from taking cases of
sexual harassment to court.
I would like to close and really
look forward to the discussion.
These are difficult
times, to say the least.
But America's history--
I need that back.
Can I have that back?
Thank you.
America's history is, of course,
filled with difficult times.
And women have always been
among the first to rise.
At the risk, again, of
pandering at Radcliffe,
the historian Gerda
Lerner once counseled,
"Always ask, what
did the women do
while the men were doing
what the textbook tells
us was important?"
And here, just again in the
realm of inspiring historical
tidbits, 4,500 women
launched campaigns for office
before the ratification of
the 19th Amendment in 1920.
And somewhat amazingly, given
the times, more than 3,000
won those races.
And Susanna Salter, who was
the first woman ever elected
mayor in the US, was put
on the ballot in Kansas
by a group of men who thought
it would be a hilarious joke
until she won 2/3 of the votes.
So we think we have it bad.
Women were a driving
force in the movement
to abolish slavery,
and a century later,
in the civil rights movement.
We remember the
names, of course,
of Rosa Parks and Fannie
Lou Hamer, Sojourner Truth.
But women whose
names never appeared
in bold print also helped
carry these movements,
women like Alabama's
Jo Ann Robinson,
who mimeographed 35,000 leaflets
the night of Rosa Parks' arrest
to publicize the
first bus boycott.
And of course, when it came
to fighting for equal pay,
it was a woman,
Lilly Ledbetter, who
never gave up, even
when the Supreme
Court sided against her.
She appealed all the
way to President Obama,
who signed the Lilly Ledbetter
Fair Pay Act in 2009,
helping restore
protections for women
against pay discrimination.
It is clear that women
and men must unite
behind the cause of equality.
It has been a year since the
incredible women's marches.
And we've just had the
anniversary marches.
My favorite sign was one
hoisted by a middle-aged man.
[LAUGHTER]
I think that kind
of says it all.
"Not usually a sign
guy, but geez."
So influenced by Sign Guy,
who I hope to meet someday,
it does seem the right time
to ask, what are each of us
normally not that these times
suddenly require us to be?
And little girls like this
one are counting on us
to figure that out.
So thank you.
That's my daughter.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
- Is it time?
- Yeah.
- Hi.
Thank you.
- Please, yeah, if you
could just introduce
yourself, maybe, and--
- Sure.
My name is Tanya [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a Harvard
Radcliffe graduate,
a concert pianist with
interest in many disciplines.
And I try to speak
up in my hometown
about issues, irregularities,
process matters, et cetera.
So I am going to also ask
about a foreign policy
question, which is
the non-recognition
of the Armenian Genocide.
I do happen to be Armenian,
but pretend I am Norwegian.
I grew up in Turkey, so
I have made my own peace
with the issue.
But I am concerned.
I know that it can't be an
easy matter in foreign policy
because Turkey is
a military ally
and they don't want
1915 stuff recognized.
What do you think?
Wouldn't it be better
if genocides were all
recognized so that,
A, they don't repeat,
B, we call them genocide
as they happen today,
like the Rohingya?
And maybe it explains
more of what's
going on in the
Middle East today.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
I agree with you.
I think genocide
should be recognized.
I think when governments
or people or institutions
are put in a position
where they have to contort
and wiggle around and
come up with euphemisms,
I think therein madness lies.
And we, as your question--
you're polite in the way
you pose your question,
but as your question suggests,
we promised we were going
to recognize the Armenian
Genocide and we didn't.
And if you ask me why,
fundamentally, the president
initially-- the right year to
do it would have been 2009.
We had promised on the
campaign we'd just come off,
rip the Band-Aid off, and
just say to President Erdogan,
sorry, I made this commitment
and I keep my commitments.
I mean, we were really
motivated as an administration
by the set of things that
we had promised to do.
But there was-- you
might remember-- back
in 2009, a nascent normalization
process between Armenia
and Turkey.
And the president was convinced
that doing so would potentially
set back that in-the-region
reckoning among the--
between the parties.
To me, it seemed more like
a ploy on the part of Turkey
to get through April 24,
2009, the-- our first Armenian
Genocide Remembrance
Day occasion,
where we should have recognized.
And I think that
history bore that out,
that it ended up being not
a normalization process
to which there was real
sincerity to make progress.
Then the other occasion--
of course, we could have done
it any year, but just the way
government works, the
other bite at the apple
was really on the
100th anniversary
when Pope Francis recognized and
many countries and parliaments
around the world.
And there-- again, this
isn't by way of excuse.
But just to give you a
sense of the context,
we were just getting
access to Turkish bases
to fight against ISIS.
And there was a
fear that Erdogan,
given his erratic way of
dealing with everything and his
anti-Americanism and
so forth, would just--
would actually sooner
have ISIS caliphate
survive than allow Americans
to use these bases in the wake
of the genocide recognition.
So this is why they pay--
President Obama didn't really
pay them the big bucks.
But these are
really tough calls.
But I think I come back
to your first premise.
It's just, in general--
it will serve you well
over time if you--
if we as a government
and if we as people--
if we tell the truth.
Yep.
- Yes, hi, my--
[CLEARS THROAT]
Sorry, I have a sore throat.
My name is Ann Eldridge.
And I wanted to ask a question
about relationships between men
and women in the
diplomatic service
and in national
security in general.
I happen to have a classmate--
class of 1957-- who
is a retired diplomat.
And she was married to
a classmate who was also
a diplomat and served--
they both served in
many areas of the world.
And actually, her career--
starting out in the 1960s doing
this--
is just replete with
the kinds of challenges
that you described, including
being told that, well, he
has this position and we
thought you were coming along
to be his secretary.
But I happened to be reading
her memoir, which just came out
this year, just at the time
that Vice President Pence was
talking about how it
is impossible to get
into the elevator with a
woman who is not Mother.
And the situations that you
describe in which men so
vastly outnumber women and
women have to face situations
where they will be the
only woman in a context,
and then adding onto that,
the uneasiness that is now
pervading the whole question
of male-female relationships--
what if I say this?
What if I do that?
I just wonder if
you could comment
on strategies that can address
those kinds of challenges.
- Your answer's probably--
and the answer of
people here would
be better than mine,
maybe people who
have reflected on this more.
I think the
sensitization by virtue
of the public conversation
is already a step.
And I think that, right now, if
you take just one institution
which is where the
diplomatic corps lives,
it would have been great if
Secretary Tillerson, as part
of this conversation,
had come out--
He's so focused on the State
Department and the building
and the positions and
the Foreign Service,
but to make this a feature
of that, which I think
is way too inward-looking.
I think he's way too
inward-looking generally.
I wish he'd tell us what
wars he wants to end
and problems he wants
to solve in the world.
But since he's not
that guy, at least
if he's going to
deal with bureaucracy
and make that his
passion, this is something
that you can deal with
incentives and disincentives
and structures and airings.
But it's very hard
to do that when
Donald Trump is your president.
And so that's why when
it comes to, at least,
the diplomatic world,
even though it feels
like you can have a conversation
hived off from politics,
it's about getting
rid of people who
aren't dedicated to figuring
out how to manage this issue.
It really is about--
and I think-- there have
been interesting writings.
Jake Sullivan, who was
Secretary Clinton's policy
guy in the campaign is one
of the most impressive people
I met in my eight
years in government.
He came out in the wake of some
of the kinds of disclosures
that I referenced today and
just talked about himself.
Now, I would see him
as in the upper 1%
of 1% of enlightened,
progressive men
that I came across
in government.
And there are many, but
I mean really top tier.
And yet, he was the one-- he
writes a long piece saying,
here are all the ways
in which I failed,
because it isn't enough just to
be progressive and then neutral
when that culture, which is
so subtle and hard to break
through in, exists around me.
And so here's a list
of the kinds of things
I wish I had done
as a progressive guy
while I was in a
position of power.
He was Secretary Clinton's
deputy chief of staff
and then was on the campaign.
So I refer you to that article.
I mean, I think we have
to change our leadership.
And then our leadership
needs to find a way
to be more proactive.
But one of the reasons
I mention all the feeder
information about think tanks
and media and panels and--
that in this world of
diplomacy, it really
would make a difference
if we started
having an equal number of
people doing national security
PhDs at the Kennedy
School, and if we
started also internalizing
in our hiring
the kinds of different
decisions women
have to make at different
parts in their career
and then make it easier
for them to hop back
in if they've taken
time out, let's say,
to have a baby or something.
Anyway, so there's
a lot one can say.
But I think the first
thing we have to do
is just-- it's back to
politics, unfortunately.
- Jay [? Gleason. ?] You're
right that it would be nice
if Secretary Tillerson
would tell us
how he wants to end the war in
Libya, which Barack Obama has
called the worst mistake
of his presidency.
You and Susan Rice and
the woman that you once
referred to as a
monster, Hillary Clinton,
were leading advocates
for that assault on Libya,
whereas at the same time, men
in the cabinet, like Bob Gates
and Tom Donilon and
then John Brennan
were very much reluctant to take
on that type of intervention.
So I can't help but
wonder whether women
are becoming worse warmongers
and cold-blooded killers
than men are.
- Well the number of factual
inaccuracies that are implicit
or that were stated
in your question
do make me question whether
you were in the room with all
this vivid detail about
who was on what side
because much of what's
been written is inaccurate.
But let me talk about
the intervention
in Libya, which seems
to be the-- if I gather,
the focus of your question.
So in Libya, we
had a circumstance
that we were
confronted with, which
is that you had people who had
risen up against a dictator who
was threatening to hunt the
people down like cockroaches,
who had turned its sights
on Benghazi, which was where
the revolution had started,
and where tens of thousands
of peaceful protesters
were gathering
every night in the main square.
The Arab League called--
had a meeting, an
unprecedented meeting,
where it expelled Libya
from the Arab League
and called for the world,
the international community
to use all necessary means
to protect civilians.
Then the British and the
French proposed a no-fly zone.
Gaddafi-- we don't need to--
Gaddafi wasn't using his
planes to carry out atrocities.
All the evidence
we had was that it
was his militia on the ground
who were hunting people down.
And a no-fly zone basically
would not be effective.
So we went to the United
Nations, which other than 9/11,
basically had not
authorized the use of force
to protect civilians in
more than two decades.
And amazingly, the
UN Security Council,
the arbiter of
international law,
authorizes the use of
all necessary measures
to protect civilians,
partly because they
knew what Gaddafi was capable
of and what he was explicitly
stating he was going to do.
So the president then joined
with a coalition of countries
in order to carry out
the intervention called
for by the Arab League, by
the UN Security Council,
and by the Libyan resistance.
As it happened, in the
wake of the intervention,
one of the things that the
same people had been calling
for intervention were
absolutely adamant
about was no foreign
presence, no foreign troops,
no foreign police, no nothing.
And in the wake of
what was initially
a very beautiful time where
independent media flowered,
civil society, women's
organizations, and the scrum
of politics turned very
tribal, very messy,
and with a division--
a profound division
within the society between
Islamists and a more secular
model.
And Libya's in a terrible
state today and people
are suffering the
consequences of what
amounts to a civil war, a
low-grade civil war with ISIS
also now at the foothold.
I think the challenge--
and I'm reckoning
with this along with
everything else--
is knowing what we
knew on the front end.
All we knew was what we knew.
And we knew also--
there are other
people in line also
who are going to want to speak.
But in the wake of
800,000 people getting
killed in Rwanda, given
how explicit Gaddafi was.
And given what I really
do believe to be the case,
which is had we not--
what you would
have, I believe, is
the massacre, which would
have been pretty ugly.
But no one will know.
It's a counterfactual.
I have no idea how bad
it would have been.
Maybe it would have
been better than Gaddafi
himself was saying
he wanted to make it.
And you would not have Libya
of the pre-revolution Libya.
It's not like you'd have
a stable Libya today.
Look at Syria.
There's an example
of no intervention.
And is that a stable place
where those kinds of divisions--
- All kinds of
intervention in Syria.
- I'm sorry?
- There's all kinds
of intervention
in Syria, direct and proxy.
In the UNSC 1973 did not
call for regime change.
You can't cite anywhere
where it said regime change.
The AU--
- But for all neccessary
measures to protect civilians.
- The AU--
- OK, I think I've given
you the best answer I can.
- --and the Arab league did
not call for regime change.
- We're good.
All right.
Thanks for coming.
Hope you enjoyed it.
- Hi, I'm Robert Cooper.
I love that photo of all
the male Secretaries-General
of the UN.
And I wondered if you have any
comment on the last selection
process where there were several
qualified women candidates.
My personal favorite,
since I'm from New Zealand,
would've been Helen Clark.
But there were
several candidates.
I wonder if you have any
insights on that process.
- I have big insights,
because the United States--
fortunately for
the United States--
gets to be very central to it.
And within that process, the 15
members of the Security Council
choose the successor
to Ban Ki-moon,
chose the successor
to Ban Ki-moon.
And because the five
permanent members have a veto,
well, ultimately, the United
States has more than 1/15,
probably, of influence
in all of this.
So this process, for
the very first time,
was public and transparent.
And for the first
time, the candidates
for Secretary-General had to
perform and answer questions
before the broader membership
of the General Assembly,
which I will say I did not
think would necessarily--
I thought it was the right
thing to do, of course, in terms
of legitimacy and
broader ownership,
but I didn't
necessarily think it
would produce a better outcome.
I thought there'd be a fair
amount of grandstanding and--
but it really was--
it really changed the dynamic.
And it meant that, among
the-- and I forget now--
I think it was 11
candidates we had,
more women competed this time--
I think five or six
women competed--
than all the prior races for all
the other secretary generalship
combined.
So that was the other thing
about making it public
and having an emphasis on having
a woman Secretary-General.
There was a group of countries
that was constituted called
the Friends of a Woman
Secretary-General,
and really banging the drum
about the importance of having
a lot of women candidates and--
with the hope that
we would-- we,
the 15, and specifically
the five permanent,
would end up with a
woman Secretary-General.
So these public
debates meant that each
of these candidates, including
Helen Clark-- everybody
performed.
And weirdly, countries as
diverse as Saudi Arabia,
France, Togo, Thailand--
they all came out
of those sessions
believing that Guterres
was heads and shoulders--
or heads and tails,
however you say it--
above the rest in terms
of his qualification.
He's a former prime
minister and former head
of the UN Refugee Agency.
One of the interesting
things was the main thing
he had to answer for, he
was very explicit about it--
he's like, I'm not a woman.
And I think, basically,
if I weren't running,
I would think that there should
be a woman Secretary-General.
But here's what I've done for
women throughout my career.
And half his cabinet when he
was prime minister was women.
All of his senior--
not all.
I think it was a slim majority
of his senior appointments
when he was head of the
Refugee Agency were women.
So he had an account, not
just on appointments, but also
on policies about what
he had done for women.
And in the end, while
the United States
had-- there were more
than one candidate
that we would have supported
as Secretary-General,
Guterres was the only one
that we could get all five
of those countries
to agree upon.
So a couple of the other women--
and I'm not going to out my
colleagues on the Security
Council.
But a couple of
the other women who
we thought were
very compelling were
voted against by permanent
members, which basically--
so they're [? doomed. ?]
Now, you could say, well,
does this mean only
the guys are going
to be the consensus candidates?
Because these guys--
I was one of 15-- these
guys casting the ballots.
I think in this
case what shocked
me is that Russia was prepared
to live with Guterres, somebody
who had a record of pushing
for human rights and women's
rights, very-- just a very
progressive politician.
But the fact that we actually
had the broader pool and it
felt like a level--
I mean, given the record I've
describe, this is hard to say.
But it felt like
people were being
judged on the basis of how
they, for instance, answered
questions about the
Libya intervention
or answered questions about--
they weren't asked about
the Armenian Genocide.
People had to perform and
show their capabilities
and lay out a program for
what they were going to do.
And it has to be said, Guterres
is the one now who's going to--
the Secretary-General is the one
who's going have to deal with
this--
the Guardian expose
and all the allegations
of abuse and harassment.
But he has also just announced
that, for the first time,
the senior appointments within
the UN are completely 50/50.
I think it's-- where's Adam?
Is it 50-50 or a little more--
yeah, basically even a
majority, now, of women.
Ban Ki-moon was very
outspoken on these issues.
But if you look at the
gap between the words
and the actual appointments,
there's a big gap.
So that's an example
of a campaign promise
that Guterres has already
kept within a year of arriving
in the job.
- Hi, first off, I
think it's an honor.
I didn't think I'd ever
be asking you a question.
I admire you so much.
So my question--
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
- I just want to say that--
and I've read your first book
during my time in undergrad.
I focused a lot on
the Syrian crisis.
But my question is about Syria,
specifically President Assad,
who is a war criminal.
My question is, will we
ever be able to hold him
accountable for these attacks?
And there's now recent reports
that there's other chemical
attacks happening in eastern--
is it Ghouta?
- Ghouta, yeah.
- Those questions that--
so really, my question
there is, will there ever
be a solution there?
This conflict
continues to happen
and we're talking
about fighting ISIL.
But you will not
ultimately, in my opinion,
defeat ISIL until you
solve the Assad problem.
So that's my question.
- Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
- But it's such an
honor to be here.
So thank you.
- Thank you very much, sir.
Thank you.
Let me take your question,
though, in two parts,
because the first
question was on Assad's
personal accountability,
and then the second,
more the structural question
about whether the regime and--
so first, on accountability,
I mean, right now,
he's operating with a sense of--
and has been for some time--
operating with a sense
of great impunity.
Fundamentally, the economic
sanctions that have been put
in place, the tools in
the toolbox that are about
de-legitimation and stigma--
those just-- those have
had no impact on him.
Now, whether military force--
taking to heart the point that
the earlier question addressed,
which is military force
is a very uncertain tool.
And you can't deal with
these underlying fissures
and cleavages in the society.
So whether that would have made
a difference, we don't know.
And that's, again,
something I'm going
to have to grapple with in
the book that I'm writing
and President Obama himself is
grappling with in the memoir
that he's writing.
But we tried--
I tried, when I was
ambassador, to bring
an international criminal
court referral to the Security
Council, because that's
when-- since Assad's not going
to refer himself, and because
Syria is not a state party,
the court has no
jurisdiction to say, hey,
there's a guy running a country
who's killing his people
and gassing these people.
So I tried that
and Russia vetoed
it, one of a half-dozen
vetoes that Russia
extended on Syria while I
was at the Security Council.
And so it's tempting, in
the wake of that, to think,
he's got Russia and
Iran behind him.
He's winning on the battlefield.
Military force is not going to
be employed, which is the one,
maybe, coercive tool
that hasn't been tried.
Maybe it could
make a difference.
And so this guy is--
whatever, home free.
There's not a lot
of history that
cuts in that
direction, which isn't
to say that tomorrow
there's going
to be some big turn
of fortune for him.
My first career, as I
mentioned, was in the Balkans.
And if you had told me
when I left to come here
to go to law school here
that Slobodan Milosevic
would end up in prison by the
International Criminal Tribunal
for Yugoslavia, or Ratko Mladic,
who just seemed invulnerable
in very similar ways--
and again, very different
set of circumstances.
NATO did get involved on
the ground in Yugoslavia.
That made a big difference.
But what tends to happen,
even in countries where you
don't have something like
you had in the Balkans,
is just the infighting
and the rivalries within
the administration itself
combined with what we have now,
which we didn't have
initially back then,
which is the documentation and
the preservation of evidence, ,
means that it is less likely
to be a foreign plucking
or imposition of something and
more likely to be some kind
of internal fissure
at some point.
But that's not very
satisfying to people who are--
have been victims.
400,000, 500,000 people
have been killed,
it looks like, in Syria, as
you say, the gas attacks,
this genie out of the
bottle that we thought
was squarely sealed in there
from the time of Saddam
Hussein.
So the larger
question before one
could even imagine this
infighting or Assad meeting
his political demise and
then potentially getting
extradited to face
justice is the question
of a political solution to
what's happening in Syria.
And Liz mentioned
The Final Year,
this movie that has just come
out about Obama's last year
where Obama and his team granted
almost full access, basically,
to a team of filmmakers.
And one of the things
that's captured
in the film that's kind of the
heart of the film is Syria.
And the efforts that
Secretary Kerry made are--
because it only
captures the final year,
it only shows him
in the final year
to get Russia, Iran, the
Europeans, the Arabs, the Gulf
Arabs, everybody
under the same tent
to try to put enough
pressure on the opposition
and on the regime.
And when you see this
film, I mean, there are--
if nothing else, it'll just
make you love John Kerry.
You see him, at times,
staggering up the stairs,
just so exhausted because he's
been going from a Yemen meeting
to a Paris climate meeting,
Cuba normalization, Syria.
And again, it's A for effort.
But none of us--
we didn't get the
results that we wanted.
And yet, the one way
I know we will not
have a solution for Syria is for
none of that effort to occur.
And that's the world
we're in now, where--
the way international
diplomacy works for now,
before China begins
to flex its muscles,
as it will at some
point in these areas--
but it's like a pickup--
it's like pickup basketball.
Someone is picking people and
pulling them into the tent
and putting forward
political agreements.
We have a military, a tactical
approach to defeating ISIS.
As you said, we have
nothing, as the United States
or the broader
international community,
aimed at getting at the
underlying causes of ISIS.
And that just has to change.
And I'm hopeful-- the
only hope I have is
that our military, which has
performed so ably in achieving
this very important
tactical victory of ending
the caliphate, in
my experience--
and the same Chairman
of the Joint Staff today
was the one that we had,
Joe Dunford, who's superb.
But in my experience
in the situation
we're in, whether on Libya
or Syria or anything else,
it's the military saying,
where's the governance?
How are we going to
deal with the underlying
causes of why people went
into ISIS in the first place?
Because they know
it's just whack-a-mole
with military force alone.
And so maybe that's
the-- the tail will
wag the dog eventually and we'll
start to get some diplomacy out
of this administration.
- --ask their questions because
we're going to have to--
- No problem.
- Just hear their
questions and then--
- Yeah, I'll take
all your questions
and I'll write down
my yes/no answers.
- Hi, Liam deClive-Lowe,
aspiring political organizer
and undergraduate student
here at the Harvard Extension
School.
In your presentation, you
talked about this surge
in candidates, especially
women candidates,
who are now running for office.
And obviously, in
those elections,
foreign policy's an
enormously complex issue
that has a huge impact on
the way that people vote.
So based on your
experience, what
is your advice to this
new slew of candidates
about how to talk about foreign
policy on the campaign trail?
And number two, do
you have any plans
to join those ranks of
candidates as one yourself,
potentially, in the future?
- I did until that
guy scared me off.
I thought I--
- My name's [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a woman in tech.
And the work that
you're doing in terms
of emphasizing the importance
of women in various roles
is super critical.
You've been personally a
great role model for me,
whether you meant it or not.
So it's great to be here.
My question for you
is about the comment
you made at the end regarding
truth and facts, which has
been such a challenge for us.
I do think it's the biggest
risk for democracy for us.
What are your thoughts
regarding the responsibility
that tech companies have?
And what's the role
of government in that?
Thank you so much.
- Thank you very much.
- Hi, thank you.
My name is Guy.
I'm a genocide
survivor from Darfur.
Before coming to America,
I lived in Israel
also for five years.
And then I'm currently an asylum
seeker in the United States.
Thank you for your
magnificent contribution
to this global society.
My question is, America has
contributed to the world
so much, but we still
have our problems.
I have some
classmates that I ask.
And your thoughts on
America's contribution
to the global society makes
them a little bit uncomfortable
because they feel like
they have given so much.
What is a better way
that we can do and stop
all these crises that are
happening outside America?
And also, where America stands
today, and the crises that
are happening in
Libya, the slave
trade and torture
that is happening--
I don't know if you saw it.
Yesterday it was on the news.
I don't want to
take too much time.
But for also the
international community--
the International
Criminal Court, the ICC,
has issued a
warrant for arrest--
to arrest al-Bashir,
the president of Sudan.
But these guys are still
moving from country to country.
Who is responsible
in implementing
the court order of the ICC?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hi, I'm Hans Schattle.
I teach in the political
science department
at Yonsei University
in Seoul, South Korea.
But New England's my
home, so it's really nice
to see you here in person.
I followed your
career trajectory back
in the early 1990s.
I was working as a news
reporter locally at the time
here in Massachusetts.
And it was really something
to see your dispatches
in the Boston Globe during the
Bosnian War, and of course,
everything that's followed.
One of my big frustrations
in international relations
is that we talk so much
about balance of power,
and understandably so, but
we give correspondingly
little airtime to the idea
of balancing responsibility.
So I'm wondering, in your years
in government, and especially
at the United Nations
in the last few years,
did you come away from that
time with any new insights that
could inspire us a little bit
about how we might think more
comprehensively,
maybe holistically,
about how to manage
responsibilities
on issues, global warming,
migrants, refugees?
We could, of course, talk
about R2P and the difficulty
in rehabilitating that
concept after Libya.
I mean, IR now is so much
bigger than just diplomacy,
foreign ministries.
We have corporations.
Look at Davos this week, NGOs,
schools and universities,
churches, everyday
citizens on Twitter.
And
There's so much out
there and I feel
as if there's a lot of work
in the field that's still
ahead of us in terms
of consolidating
our thinking about how
we can solve problems
more effectively that
transcend nation states.
And of course, the UN is our--
it's the best venue we've
got, but it only goes so far.
So any thoughts on that
would be really great.
Great.
Thank you.
Great, OK.
Wonderful.
Thank you all.
And thanks for staying
through all of this.
It's OK if you
have to leave, too.
So first, for the aspiring
political organizer--
Liam, I think you
said your name was--
we learned yesterday
at Radcliffe,
through-- or two days ago
at Radcliffe that only 24%
of eligible Harvard students
had voted in the midterm
election in 2014.
Aspiring political organizer,
there's a task for you.
Why don't we all chip
in and figure out
how we can get that up just
way, way higher, as something
we can do in the here and now?
But your question was about how
to talk about foreign policy.
And I guess I would
acknowledge that we have-- we,
the Obama administration,
did not crack that code,
it's fair to say.
The fact that we now
have not only the Trump
base with "America
First" and this kind
of discredited
political ideology
that has lived within our
political ecosystem for more
than a hundred years, but the
fact that that is now governing
and that we're pulling out
of the kinds of things that
put my world view to
one side, but just
as a matter of
pragmatism, are needed,
whether on climate or
on terrorism, alienating
our allies or
insulting our allies,
and thus really
jeopardizing our ability
to call on them
when we need them,
whether in the context of
international framework or even
just bilaterally.
So the fact that it's on
the left and the right--
and I'm not a believer
in false equivalence,
because only one party
is governing and doing
these things.
But the left wing of
the Democratic Party
is not very enthusiastic about--
or some of them,
anyway, are not very
enthusiastic about the
kinds of investments
in our national security,
whether in the form
of our military or our
diplomacy or in terms
of international engagements.
And so this-- these
wings are very different.
And one has a much
more inclusive model
and doesn't have the
xenophobia and racism
or any of that stuff.
But in terms of the
belief of the balance
between the domestic
enterprise and all
that is left to be done here
at home and what we do abroad,
there ends up being an overlap,
at times, in prescription.
So that worries me a lot.
And on communications,
I've talked
to some of my favorite members
of Congress about this.
We have to find a way
to talk about climate
that feels relevant to
people's lives here.
And it won't be by talking
about the Paris Agreement.
And some people ask me
sometimes about my book
and is there a thesis
undergirding it.
And the only thing I can
tell you is I will not--
the words "liberal
international order"
will not appear in my book.
I aspire in telling
stories to reach people.
Yes, that is my
unconcealed worldview,
is that we have to invest
in our common security
and our common humanity.
But I've got to
find a way and we've
got to find a way
to communicate that
in a manner that's accessible
beyond our like-minded cohort.
So I don't have a great answer.
But I think this question
of how to communicate,
how to talk about foreign
policy is really important.
And we went through
this on Ebola.
One thing President
Obama did, which
I really admired
at the time, but I
think has to be
supplemented, is people
were in full-on panic in
this country about Ebola.
You remember when patient
Duncan died in Texas
and some of the
nurses got infected.
And the polling was horrific,
even in democratic districts,
of people wanting
to close our doors
and not even let health workers
come back into this country
or to quarantine them
when they came back in.
And this was at a time
where more Americans
had married Kardashians than
had died of Ebola, right?
And so President
Obama didn't say
what I just said, which would--
of course, you're not going to--
I went to West Africa in the
middle of the Ebola crisis.
I was scared.
I mean, fear is--
it's a legitimate thing
that one can feel.
But how to meet people
where they are and--
if you just, whether on
terrorism, refugees, Ebola,
climate-- if you just cite
statistics for people,
a lot of people,
that's good enough.
But there's a group that
aren't-- the Trump base,
but of people who
can be convinced,
but whom we have not
brought into the fold,
for whom statistics and just
the facts aren't meeting them
viscerally where they are when
they are feeling those fears,
which of course
are stoked, then,
by people who shouldn't
be-- who should know better.
In terms of tech companies, let
me-- let me just acknowledge,
I think, the importance of the
question in the following way.
People ask us about the
Russia interference,
which I'm surprised
I haven't been asked
about, and with good reason.
And they ask, should
we have done more?
And should Obama have come out
and not just the intelligence
agencies before the election?
And all the rest and--
we're all going to be asking
ourselves questions about what
we might have done differently.
But one thing I just want
to convey is when we--
so cyber security and cyber
threats by foreign nations
is something that we have
developed over the last decade,
plus an infrastructure within
the US national security
establishment to deal with,
Department of Justice,
Department of Homeland
Security, Defense Department,
intelligence in terms
of who's doing what.
When it comes to
fake news and ad
buys and your-- the
de-centralized world
of your existence and
other citizens' existence,
whether here or
anywhere else, there's
no obvious government lever.
And that's why this
conversation that's
happening in Silicon Valley, as
unsatisfying as I have found it
up to this point, really
is a conversation that
should have been happening
four or five years ago.
And we should have
done everything
in our power-- we should
have done more to try
to catalyze that conversation.
But fundamentally, it's going to
be on that community of people
to make things happen.
And then I just merged
the last two questions
because [? Gees' ?] question was
on how to stop crises and share
burdens better, and then
the other was on balance
of responsibility,
which I think also
is another version
of burden-sharing.
Part of the answer to the
first question about how
you sell foreign
policy in a broader way
will entail being able
to better describe
what the international
order is buying us.
And Donald Trump has had this
worldview throughout his life.
He has not changed at all.
He feels like we are
getting ripped off.
And he has found something,
again, in his base,
but also in others
who have supported him
and now may have--
maybe have melted away.
But we need to
show-- for instance,
in my world of UN peacekeeping,
everybody focuses on the fact
that it's a $8.5 billion budget
for UN peacekeepers, 100,000 UN
peacekeepers in the world,
and we pay 28% of that.
They don't focus on
the fact that 72%
is paid for by other countries.
And moreover, the troops who
actually are peacekeepers,
who are risking their lives and
dying at record rates almost
never come from
the United States.
We have a tiny
percentage of that.
Climate, I think we
made good headway.
But responsibility is something
you hear a lot from the biggest
emitters, from China and India.
And their conception
of responsibility
is historical, which
is really important.
If you're them, you're
like, wait a minute.
How can we just start
caring about climate
when we are now needing coal
in order to develop and deal
with our growing populations?
And I think what we
succeeded in doing,
partly by leveraging the
relationships that Obama had
built with Xi and with Modi,
is for the first time now
we have a language about
responsibility that is lateral
and in the present about
emissions as being what
dictates your responsibility.
But we still have to
acknowledge the historical
and the disparities
and so forth there.
So I think a lot of creative
thinking needs to be done.
And the questions that
emphasize language and framing
are right because we
have to do better.
If we are going to go
forward and actually
be able to execute a worldview
that is rooted in the sense
that we are connected and
that it is in our interests,
also, to look out for others,
whether at home or abroad,
we're going to
have to sell that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]